Merci d'être là ce matin.
Nous sommes très contentes de vous avoir ici.
Je voudrais bien parler français.
Peut-être quand j'arrive à la gloire, je pourrais parler français.
Mais je suis reconnaissant pour Myra qui me traduit ce matin.
J'aimerais en ce moment prier pour que le Seigneur prépare nos cœurs pour ce que nous allons attendre ce matin.
Seigneur, nous sommes tellement reconnaissants d'être là avec ces femmes ce matin.
Merci pour ce privilège qui est de partager avec elles ce matin.
Nous prions que ton esprit vienne et nous aide.
Que tu puisses m'aider lorsque je partage.
Que tu puisses aider Myra quand elle traduit.
Et que tu puisses donner à tes chères sœurs la compréhension pour écouter et obéir à ta parole.
Nous prions que le Seigneur Jésus soit exalté.
Que tu puisses être heureux avec ce moment-là.
Et que tu puisses être heureux.
En nom de Jésus.
Amen.
Dans cette première session, j'aimerais partager avec vous l'appel du Seigneur pour cet appel qu'il nous donne.
Je suis demandé de partager avec Dieu.
Je suis demandé de partager avec Dieu la création de nous.
Son design pour nous, les femmes, être des aidés.
On m'a demandé de partager par rapport à notre création, à la part de Dieu, et son dessein pour nous.
Pour être des aides.
Mais avant de se plonger dans ce sujet, j'aimerais souligner deux priorités fondamentales dans nos vies en tant qu'une femme chrétienne.
Nous devons s'attendre, au premier et au premier, dans nos cœurs, que nous avons créés pour donner la glorie à Dieu.
Tout d'abord, il faut qu'on reconnaisse dans nos cœurs qu'on a été créés avant tout pour glorifier Dieu.
Et nous ne pouvons véritablement le faire que quand on embrasse ce dessein des dieux pour nous, avec de la joie.
Il est aussi d'une très grande importance que nous soyons engagés à obéir les Écritures.
Nous devons demander au Seigneur de nous donner des cœurs qui soient disposés à dire oui à n'importe ce qu'il va nous demander de faire.
Et lorsqu'on accepte cet appel de Dieu pour nous en tant que femmes, ça veut dire que plusieurs fois, nous allons devoir nier l'idéologie dans notre culture.
Mais quand on accepte de tout cœur le dessein des dieux pour nous, lorsque nous le faisons, nous allons trouver une grande joie et des bénédictions.
Donc ma prière pour nous en tant que femmes ce matin, c'est qu'au moment où nous partons, nous allons repartir avec une meilleure compréhension de notre rôle dans notre foyer et aussi par rapport à la relation avec nos marines.
Et la manière comme nous pourrons accomplir fidèlement ce rôle d'une façon que bénéficie notre mariage, qui surtout magnifie et loue au Seigneur.
Donc je voudrais commencer au début.
Je voudrais commencer par nous commencer par l'objet de Dieu en créant la première femme.
J'aimerais regarder tout d'abord l'objectif de Dieu à créer la première femme au tout début.
Donc si vous pourriez ouvrir vos Bibles avec moi en Genèse chapitre 1.
Et nous allons voir Genèse 1, versets 26 et 27.
Nous allons voir Genèse 1, versets 26 et 27.
Then God said, let us make man in our image after our likeness.
Puis Dieu dit, faisons l'homme à notre image selon notre ressemblance, et qu'il domine sur le poisson de la mer, sur les oiseaux du ciel, sur le bétail, sur toute la terre, et sur tous les reptiles qui rampent sur la terre.
Dieu créa l'homme à son image, et il le créa à l'image de Dieu. Il créa l'homme et la femme.
Donc aussi l'homme et la femme ont été créés à la ressemblance de Dieu.
Ils étaient égaux en valeur.
Mais ils ont aussi été créés différents.
Le premier jour de la création, le Seigneur a créé de la lumière.
Et les Écritures apportent que Dieu vit que la lumière était bonne.
On le troisième jour de la création, Dieu rassembla les eaux en un seul endroit, et il les appela la mer.
Et il l'a appelé la terre, la terre.
Et encore une fois nous lisons que Dieu vit que cela est bon.
Au quatrième jour, Dieu a créé le soleil et la lune et tous les corps célestes.
Et le verset 18 nous dit encore une fois, et Dieu vit que cela était bon.
Au cinquième jour, le Seigneur a créé les oiseaux et les animaux de la mer.
Et encore une fois, Dieu a regardé sa création et il a dit, cela était bon.
Puis le sixième jour, le grand créateur de l'univers, il a créé les animaux de la terre et des champs.
Et je pense que vous savez déjà ce qu'il a dit, c'est qu'il était bon.
Ensuite le Seigneur a créé l'homme et la femme.
Et il les a donné la domination sur la terre.
Et les Écritures nous disent que Dieu a résumé la création avec ces mots-là.
Et Dieu a vu tout ce qu'il avait fait et voici que cela était très bien.
Et lorsqu'on rentre dans le chapitre 2, c'est comme si l'Esprit faisait un zoom pour nous montrer l'homme et la femme.
En Genèse chapitre 2, verset 7, ça dit,
Alors le Seigneur Dieu forma l'homme de la poussière du sol.
Il souffla dans ses narines les souffles de vie et l'homme devint un être vivant.
Et là, pour la première fois, au verset 18, on lit pour la première fois le Seigneur qui dit, il n'est pas bon.
Il n'est pas bon que l'homme soit seul.
Est-ce que vous voyez le contraste frappant?
Après avoir prononcé toute sa création comme étant très bon.
Pour la première fois, Dieu dit, il n'est pas bon.
Il n'est pas bon que l'homme soit seul.
Et dans sa grande sagesse et bonté, le Seigneur avait une solution pour ce problème.
Il dit, je ferais une aide qui lui soit assortie.
Maintenant, imaginez, le Lord God was there.
Adam had personal communion avec lui.
Imaginez ça, Dieu le Seigneur était là.
Adam avait une communion personnelle avec Dieu.
Mais Dieu a dit qu'il avait besoin de quelque chose de plus.
Le Seigneur avait déjà créé tous les animaux.
Ils étaient beaux et uniques.
Et on nous dit que les chiens sont le meilleur ami de l'homme.
Mais le chien, dans ce contexte, n'était pas ce dont Adam avait besoin.
Dieu aurait pu faire un autre homme avec qui Adam pourrait parler et philosopher avec.
Mais ce n'est pas ce dont il avait besoin.
Amid plenty, all around him,
Dieu savait exactement ce qu'il avait besoin.
Au milieu de toute cette abondance qu'il avait autour d'Adam,
Dieu savait exactement ce dont il avait besoin.
Alors il a dit, je vais créer une aide pour lui.
Et il créa une contrepartie pour Adam.
Une femme ou littéralement en hébreu, ça veut dire une femme homme.
She man, femme homme.
Je pense que...
Elle, lui, quelque chose comme ça.
Elle était différente de l'homme dans son sexe, mais pas dans sa nature.
Elle n'était ni inférieure ni supérieure à lui.
Dieu a fait une femme qui était égale à l'homme.
Elle était comparable à lui.
Elle était là pour l'aider et le complémenter.
Elle n'était pas là pour le concurrencer.
Et c'est important pour nous de reconnaître que cette première femme a été créée pour l'homme et à partir de l'homme.
On voit cette vérité réitérée dans le Nouveau Testament.
1 Corinthians 11, 8 et 9
22. 22.
44. 44.
44. 44. 44.
44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44.
44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44. 44